your producer Julie who I think died
just before this film started is that
right yeah tell me about collaborating
with her and what her producing meant to
your realizing this film and I'm sorry
to start with such an emotional thing
but I think she would be a happy that
we're up here she was uh remarkable you
know um you know like I said she gave me
my first job she worked with gentleman
named Lawrence bender who I believe is
here and she hired me and we never
stopped working together after that um
these would be this story she my mother
my father read at first and my mother
and my wife and then Julie read it and
Julie hounded me for a decade at least a
decade to adapt it she knew that it was
a story I could tell or should tell and
I just kept getting involved with other
things or other reasons I procrastinate
but she insisted and you know her heart
is stamped all over it there reminds me
so much of her other people who know
Julie will see that
so she was everywhere and you know she
lost her literally right as the funding
came together and it's was odd
she stayed present we didn't have any
Gers or yurts as we say in English and
somebody happened to be driving through
Calgary with 40 yurts in the back of
their truck and we whether she liked it
or not we credited Julie with that um
there's no other explanation really why
40 yurts worth driving through Calgary
so we decided it was her but so she was
with it's every step of the way and
thank you for bringing her up she the
film that would not exist without her
first spirit this is a film that's
adapted from a short story by Rob and
Roy laughs and the short story is a
short story and there are grains of this
film in it but really just grains what
was the essence of what you wanted to
preserve and how did you go about
inventing so much of everything that
happens in this film you know what the I
read the story today
I hadn't read it many many I did too
it's it's absolutely exquisite and the
last paragraph he's so captured what
moved me when I read this story it's
again as he says it was about a couple
in trouble no particular reason or
explanation what trouble or why but they
were at each other's throats boy dresses
up like man gold and they disagree it
becomes violent in a similar way as does
in the bedroom
dad Yanks the costume off boy runs out
and they gather in this bush and they
just hug and in the moment of this
embrace they find themselves again you
know so the first time I read it I'm
just weeping and I'm um and I can't even
explain it I mean it took me years to
kind of figure it out but I think what
it does and I'm married a long time and
my wife is here and I love her
and anyone who is married knows how
difficult it is and it was one of the
few times I read something that
understood the value of resurrecting a
marriage that was broken and it just was
deeply deeply moving to me and so when
it came time to stretch it out I decided
I was gonna throw as much [ __ ] as I
could at that family right obviously
there's nothing more significant and
again I didn't really know where they'd
end up and I still you know don't right
but I knew that there was nothing more
challenging to a marriage than the loss
of a child I'd also experienced that
through some friends of friends and
watched it and there's nothing quite
like that and in in terms of what it
what it what it teaches us about what
what's possible in a connection right
and how easy it is to sever that at any
rate they all jumbled together and I
just thought this is a story about not
knowing where home is not knowing what
home is and I wanted them as lost as
possible so this is a story that is
largely set in Mongolia and if you guys
were watching the credits you saw a lot
of Canadian credits so I want to ask you
about adapting your story that is said
in Mongolia to Calgary and what the
opportunity was what the challenges were
and how that ended up working for better
and for worse well we did go to Mongolia
so there's a whole bunch of photography
that's shot there sort of wide masters
right and so we scouted that first
knowing we would go shoot those then
went and found places in Calgary Alberta
which would allow us to back into those
masters right
the reason Alberta or Calgary is that
it's the sister city to Alan
but or same elevation same population
same population density growth there
they share ambassadors but the real
reason is there's 800 hundred Mongolians
who live there all the Mongolians in the
film are Mongolian nobody plays him on
golian that isn't a Mongolian we and I
there's only one other place in the
North America where there were that many
Mongolians that we could actually cast
the film there was no infrastructure in
Mongolia for the budget we had to make
the film so we knew we were gonna shoot
here but if it weren't for that
Mongolian community we would never ended
up there and how did you find Jacob
because this is before he shoots room
how did your castings right after room
so he shot him but it hasn't come out
and they wouldn't show it to me they
okay so nobody has seen him really
wasn't seen it out of you fella he
tested for the film before room when he
was quite young as agent Bryan at UTA
sent me a tape of him I don't know even
how they found the script we didn't have
money but I saw this tape of this young
boy it was a year and a half younger
than this and he was spectacular so he
was always the one to beat but we'd
heard he made a movie and I'd heard
nobody would show it to me and I didn't
yet actually get to talk to the director
but I did hear from the production that
he was worth the shot that he was gonna
be good in the room you know they were
hands cars were close to their vest but
but we you know it was instantly clear
that he was the boy John and your
earliest conversation with Jordan there
are a couple of things there story
driven in terms of what its gonna mean
cinematically that you're gonna have to
shoot a documentary it's males film
within the film but in terms of
perspective in terms of representing
Wes's view of the world what were the
earliest conversations about the angles
from which you would shoot how you would
capture Wes's perspective on Mongolia
and on his parents marriage and what did
that translate into in terms of how you
actually ended up shooting the film well
there was a certain initial interview I
had with some of the producers there was
a vision they had had being done in a
very documentary style you know I was
quite clear in terms of what I said in
Jordan and I had long conversations
about this and really hung together on
it that we wanted it to really have a
sense where the landscape was controlled
and beautiful and one of the things I'm
most proud of is that it really except
for a few shots that are clearly barren
enough to be a certain part of Mongolian
how seamless the transitions are I mean
you don't know sometimes when there's a
driving shot and even now I have trouble
saying because the light and everything
we were able to balance it so
beautifully that it's seamless between a
bad goalie and shot of the Land Rover
and what we did in Calgary and that was
very important to us Jordan and I talked
a lot about you know trying to find
specific locations on what was it that
we were shooting actually quite a bit
west of Calgary on First Nations land so
there was a lot of open land there and
we were able to get you know very wide
landscapes that correspondent and open
range country that was very similar to
Mongolia but Jordan and I had a real
sense that we wanted this to be for the
landscape to be a character and I I was
a camera operator on Days of Heaven that
which we also shot in Calgary actually
not too far away so I knew the the I
knew the landscape quite a bit and
Jordan and I talked very much about the
fact that even though the style in burn
your Maps is is very different than days
of heaven that there was a sense of
people living in nature in nature being
you know a strong presence in the film
I'm wondering how you worked with your
actors and through writing and through
directing about what they're grasping at
what has kept
together and what could break them apart
and what kinds of things you had to say
to them about how you wanted those
scenes to play Thanks
well so the ground upon which this is
built was lost and I've experienced loss
most humans by the time I wrote this
head of experience law so I knew that
the ground was lost in the connected the
where they found themselves again was
going to be through the exploration of
loss or the acknowledgement of loss or
the ownership of loss right so I knew
that and so I think one of the things we
consistently worked on is how do we how
do we deny the truth of our pain does
that make sense like how do we how do we
keep a distance from acknowledging the
pain because once we start to
acknowledge the shared pain in a shared
way we start to connect and the point
was to keep these people disconnected so
in a strange way we found different ways
in which they would deny the pain in
different ways and you know the film
toys with levity and the toys with or
there's there's I really noticed it
tonight there's remarkably strange tone
shifts in this story for a scene for a
film with it's got such dramatic scenes
it bounces back and that was intentional
in the sense that we were trying to mark
the landscape of the avoidance of
intimacy John and Jordan thank you so
much for your time and thank you guys
for supporting the movie